jean marc sylvestre bonjour bonjour à
vous heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors le
président de la république
on a fait un événement est ce que ça
préfigure l'installation de la finance à
paris
alors ça sera évidemment si ça sera
aussi pour le président de la république
un début de campagne électorale à jour
n'est d'ailleurs lundi il était dans le
nord de france pour inaugurer une usine
renault usine de batteries il
s'adressait évidemment aux écologistes
et à tous ceux qui réclament une
relocalisation industrielle et yeah eh
bien il s'est déplacé dans paris pour
accueillir la direction générale de 10
puis morgan qui est l'une des plus
grandes banques d'affaires au monde et
qui va installer à paris à peu près 500
traders supplémentaire et c'est vrai que
c'est pas banal alors ce sont des
emplois qui sont créés dans la finance
qui sont localisés à paris le président
de la république a visité une salle des
marchés
c'est là où se sont toutes les
transactions sur des centaines de
milliards d'euros notamment d euros
investis dans la dette française ou dans
les dates européennes alors que jpmorgan
n'est pas la seule manche a déménagé
ainsi ce qu'on appelle ses chambres de
compensation c'est des endroits où les
banques s'échangent et relaciones avec
leur titre et ça permette de d'échangés
alors la france est celle de récupérer
ce type d'activité à haute valeur
ajoutée à haut pouvoir d'achat parce que
ce sont des emplois qui sont bien pilier
nous avez compris et le président de la
république fait la pub pour les attirer
en fait il fait son job quand même là
alors vous le disiez ça sent le break
site
est ce que c'est un effet direct du
break site oui absolument personne n'est
surpris le brick city chic type depuis
le 31 décembre de l'année dernière
la grande-bretagne n'appartient plus à
l'europe donc alors elle n'appartient
plus à l'europe depuis le vote il ya
niazi à 5 ans sa date quand même de 5
ans donc on a eu cinq ans pour se
préparer à tout ça
c'est effectif depuis le début de cette
année 31 décembre minuit donc
rétablissement des douanes des contrôles
des normes alors on a signé quelques
accords pour s'adapter à cette situation
notamment pour les non résidents au
niveau de la coordination des systèmes
de retraite de ces conditions on a vu
d'ailleurs c'était pas très évident il
ya encore beaucoup de paperasserie
affaire on a signé des accords pour les
conditions d'importation et
d'exportation notamment de produits de
produits agroalimentaires de produits de
santé et mais on a très souvent entre
nous repris où on va reprendre les
anciens accords mais pour tout ce qui
concerne la banque tout ce qui concerne
la finance est bien les choses se sont
bloquées pourquoi pas parce que
l'affluence anglaise bénéficier de ce
qu'on appelle un passeport financier qui
permettait aux bandes de travailler en
europe dans tout l'espace européen mais
sous conditions fiscales et
réglementaires et social de la grande
bretagne qui sont beaucoup plus
libéralisés qu'en europe donc pour les
banquiers du monde entier c'était très
facile très commode est très intéressant
de venir s'installer à londres pour
pouvoir accéder très facilement aux
marchés européens or ces conditions est
temps favorable londres était devenu
quasiment un paradis fiscal et
réglementaire pour les ventes ont
d'ailleurs pas oublié a que là que la
fameuse crise des subprimes en 2009 2008
2009 elle avait démarré dans les banques
anglo saxonnes parce que les capacités
de réglementation et liberté était pour
vous plus grande des garanties étaient
moins importants de londres est
quasiment je vous le disais un paradis
pour les banquiers d'où le succès de la
city qui attirait les banques du monde
entier qu'ils pouvaient donc travailler
partout en europe alors avec le break 6
qui s'est passé dans l'union européenne
a suspendu le passeport financiers les
banques ont donc perdu un certain nombre
d'avantagés notamment les avantages du
système de pouvoir aller travailler
ailleurs tout en restant à londrès dont
tu t'es obligé de déménager en europe
parce que leurs clients sont en europe
il faut dire que les grandes capitales
européennes il n'y a pas que la france à
francfort en allemagne
amsterdam se font un peu de concurrence
pour dérouler le tapis rouge et
jean-marc paris qui est compétitif ou
pas
oui alors paris a fait des efforts le
système des prélèvements obligatoires et
notamment des prélèvements fiscaux pas
très compétitifs la france est encore un
des champions du monde mais elle a fait
un peu d'effort d'ailleurs notamment
pour les ventes mais mais mais les
banques qui viennent s'installer à paris
trouve d'autres avantages le personnel
des banques d'ailleurs il a quand même
son mot à dire préfère habiter paris
plutôt plus francfort en force à leur
paraît un peu triste ou amsterdam paris
et plus de l'amour et la france quoi
qu'on dise reste quand même un des pays
les plus attractifs en europe par son
système social par son système
d'éducation et à son art de vivre alors
il faut relativiser tout ça quand même
on fera un bilan définitif dans deux ou
trois ans parce que tipi morgan installe
à paris 800 traders dont jp morgan
on a encore gardé dix neuf mille à
londres pour l'instance et va envoyer
sans doute plusieurs médias francfort
parce que c'est là qu'ils à la banque
centrale européenne à amsterdam c'est là
où il ya beaucoup de sièges sociaux
amsterdam peut devenir la vraie capitale
financière de l'europe c'est le vrai
concurrent de paris aujourd'hui et jean
marc est ce que le départ de la finance
va appauvrir la ville de londres alors
incontestablement oui
londres va perdre l'une des composantes
importantes de son dynamisme de son
activité de sa richesse parce qu'avec la
finance londres va perdre les cabinets
d'avocats les cabinets d'audit de
conseil d'analystes financiers il ya
tout un tas de profession qui gravitent
autour de la banque et qui vont suivre
la banque dont je crois que boris
johnson en appelait son parti il
travaille aux accords commerciaux
il travaille aux accords industriels de
façon à ce que les marchés anglais les
consommateurs anglais soient
approvisionnées en biens alimentaires
notamment trop des frais qui viennent
d'espagne qui viennent de bretagne en
produits industriels qui alimentent
l'industrie automobile qui est assez
puissante mais ça c'est pour alimenter
le pays profond et je crois qu'il a fait
un peu une croix sur le dynamisme de la
banque financière et notamment londres
qui était quand même sa ville dont il
était le maire sur l'a10 globalement les
premiers effets du bric sites sont quand
même un négatif pour les anglais mais
ils ne sont pas catastrophiques comme
certains avaient pu pouvoir le prévoir
les échanges se sont pas effondrés non
s'ils sont devenues très compliquées
beaucoup plus compliqué disent les
importateurs exportateurs un peu plus
long donc les prix des produits
alimentaires ont un peu augmenté parce
que les échanges je vous le disais sur
devenu trop sophistiqués
de paperasse trop de formalités tout ça
aboutit finalement à des mois sur le
prix a dépeint beau temps merci beaucoup
jean marc jean marc sylvestre un édito
écho à retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
et on vous retrouve mercredi prochain
dans la matinale de rtl france